Hide your necks, here is Claes Bang!
Welcome here!
Thank you!
We just saw a clip from Dracula.
Yes. We did.
What about you, do you think, made them give you that role?
But ... I don't want to know that!
I don't want to know about it. If there's something in there that ... No.
It should be said that
you needed a bit of makeup.
Yes.
And costume.
Yes. This might be a little bit of a spoiler,
but I'm really old in the beginning of this.
Yes.
200 years old.
How much time did it take for you to become ..?
It takes four hours.
Was it uncomfortable?
Or was it easy?
With the makeup ...
When you were in the full Dracula outfit?
It was ...
What do you say in Swedish?
Nails.
Nails. Yes, nails.
There's teeth, there's contact lenses,
there's about a kilo of plastic around this area.
And you can't see anythi ng.
When you're 200 years old, your eyes are very grey.
So you have these grey ...
I couldn't see! And then
I had this cape and a candelabrum and shit!
I was very, very
scared that I would set fire to my hair.
With this thing.
What have you ...
I mean, you're from Copenhagen.
Yes.
Can you remember when you were a child,
we were talking about Jonatan's fears as a child,
what were you scared of when you were a child?
Everything.
Everything. I was very scared when I was little.
Can you remember a time when you were scared?
You said that you were scared when you were at home alone?
Yes.
I was the same.
It was scary.
Just to walk in the door. ÇHello?È
I didn't even go in, I just went somewhere else.
Back to school or some place.
I also think it's scary being in a room where I know that I'm the most competent person.
So if something happens
it'll be up to me to fix it.
I think that's an uncomfortable feeling.
Aha. Okay.
You have no confidence that you can do it?
Confidence isn't the problem. It's been proven through the years.
Okay, so you want an adult in the room.
Yes, exactly. Or just a very competent child!
A competent child.
Are you a scared person? Are you ever scared?
Yes. I've been a coward my whole life.
And I was scared of mean boys.
Who were after me.
Who were bigger than me.
And I was scared of drunk men.
Drunk guys.
Yes, I was very ...
And as a child, I was often walking around the city.
And when I saw a drunk man
I walked ...
I was completely sure that he would say something to me, or do something.
And I thought it was horrifying.
What are you scared of today?
Drunk men.
You're doing quite well.
One of the reasons for that is a movie called The Square.
Which Ruben …stlund, the Swedish director, did.
Yes.
And you've praised Ruben …stlund
on every possible occasion.
But working together wasn't completely unproblematic?
No, but a thing like that is never unproblematic, it will never be.
But I ...
I'm extremely proud of that movie, I'm extremely proud of
the fact that I could do what he needed for his film.
But, if you're completely honest,
how sick could you get of him?
Ah, I could get so sick of him.
It's not even possible to describe!
I wanted to kill him!
You left the country ...
Yes.
It was a weekend. My wife was doing a movie in Norway,
she was a makeup artist at that time.
So I went to Norway.
And then I was sitting there
hating Ruben …stlund.
You spoke about that in an interview with L.A. Times.
And then ...
It was quite obvious that you at that point didn't think that a Norwegian was going to ...
Read it?
... read it. Because you say that
ÇNorway is terrible!È
ÇI'm telling you. Norway is the worst!È
But you shouldn't go to Bergen if you're gonna experience Norway. It will rain there!
I'm sorry, Norway!
I'm sorry.
What do you mean by this, it's the best country in the world!
Is it the country or the people?
Everything. But ...
Oh my god!
I'm in trouble now!
Because you were trying to describe how much you hated Ruben …stlund,
and you went to Norway, and even that was better than Ruben …stlund!
No, but it was like this,
it didn't go well for me, and then I was sitting there and
if I'm honest,
I didn't know if he would
want me to return to doing the movie.
It didn't go well that day.
So I was sitting in Norway thinking
maybe I'll return to Gothenburg,
where we were filming, and he will just be like Çfuck offÈ.
I didn't know.
But what was the problem with Norway? That's what I'd like to know!
It's not Norway's fault! If you lose ...
You're blaming Norway!
That's what I'm saying, it wasn't Norway's fault!
It could be Norway's fault as well.
All these things were happening.
But you know how these things are. If you feel really bad
and then you're somewhere and you think Çwhat the hell is this? I hate it!È.
This film that we're talking about now,
it brought you to Cannes and it brought you to
the Palme d'Or award in Cannes.
Yes.
And this was an incredible award for ...
Do we really want to go there?
Yes, because I want to know, what was it like for you to experience that?
I became insane in Cannes.
What happened?
I lost my ...
I don't know. It was like this, we went to Cannes with the movie.
And you can only win one award in Cannes.
You can't win the prize for best movie and then win for best script too.
You only get one.
And then it was like this: Everyone liked this movie, and everyone
were saying that this was a really good movie,
Çbut you're not going to win, because it's too funnyÈ.
Everyone was saying
Çif you get a call and they say that you should be there, you're going to win for something elseÈ.
So then I thought, ÇshitÈ,
Çmaybe I'll get the award for best male actor, then!È
It began to ...
Live in you?
Yes!
And I ...
I started to believe the hype.
Because I was reading in Variety , The Guardian, Hollywood Reporter,
they all said that I would win the award for best male actor.
When we got the call on Sunday, I thought
ÇFUCKÈ!
I'm going to get this!
And then we go there
and we're sitting there and they say
Çand best male actor isÈ and I do this!
No, I didn't do that!
But it felt like it!
I've watched the show, and I'm like this.
Clapping.
Applauding Joaquin Phoenix.
You can see clearly that I'm extremely disappointed.
And then after about ten minutes,
we win the big award.
And then we're completely euphoric, everything is fantastic.
And then ten more minutes pass, and it feels like
something's not quite right.
ÇI think they may have made a mistake.È
Even though you had received the biggest award?
Yes! I know!
And Ruben even said on stage that he shared the award with me!
Yes. It was ...
He doesn't mean that, you know.
I was calling everyone ...
Did you call everyone beforehand, all your old enemies, and tell them to go to hell?
I called all my agents and said Çwhat the hell is this?! I was supposed to get that award!È
And they were like Çlisten. This is really good.
No one watches a movie because it has won
the prize for best male actor in Cannes
but everyone watches the Gold Palm winner!
So this is very good for you, because you're great in the movie! Everyone will watch it.
It will mean a lot of business.
But it didn't feel like it?
No. It didn't.
So I called another agent. And another agent.
And everyone said the same thing.
And at this point I was really drunk.
It's the biggest party you can ...
There's so much champagne, you can't even ...
It never ends.
Fucking hell. Why am I telling this story?
So I was really drunk and then
I see Ruben …stlund returning from the press conference.
All the winners return. And I just think
Çfuck youÈ.
ÇI'm gonna hurt you.È
And after that, I knew that I had to go home.
ÇI have to go home, because I've done crazy things while I was drunk.È
And I just saw myself walking over, trying to take this golden palm and just
steal half of it or something!
It wasn't good. So I said to my wife that we had to go home. And she said
ÇAre you an idiot?!È
ÇJust have a look around! There's David Lynch, there's this person, you can talk to everyone, and they've seen your movie.È
ÇThey think you're great, what the hell!È
I said ÇI can't do it, I'm going to kill him!È
ÇI'm going to kill him!È
You would've gotten so many parts if you had killed him!
Everyone loves a crazy actor.
In any other profession, you would've been fired.
But in this one, you just would've become a  new Klaus Kinski!
Just kill Ruben …stlund!
ÇI want him in my next filmÈ, I really think everyone would've said that!
Just kill him!
I'm actually happy I didn't do it.
But when you were drunk and calling around, did you think ...
Was your goal to try to get them to redo their decision?
Were you thinking that ...
ÇWe should be able to do something about this?È
Yes! ÇCan you call them?È
ÇCan we get everyone back in that big room?È
ÇThere's been a mistake.È
ÇDid you think this through?È
ÇWe've been doing some thinking ...È
Yes.
I don't know what the hell I wanted.
When you talk about it, I agree that it sounds completely absurd that you didn't win!
But we ended up leaving the place, and that was that.
Claus, we began this conversation talking about an iconic character, Dracula.
I thought I would finish by asking a question about another iconic character,
that soon has to find yet another actor to portray him,
James Bond.
And I know that you're in ...
... what's it called ...
... the odds, or ...
The loop?
A lot of people want you to get that question.
Would you be able to do something new for that ...
You're renewing Dracula, would you be able to renew James Bond?
As with Dracula, and it would be the same with Bond, I wouldn't do something just because
it's called Bond or Dracula.
I want to read scripts.
But if they call and ask you Çdo you want to play James BondÈ you don't ask for a script!
Hell yeah, I will!
They could call you?
I don't have to see any script!
But then you'll regret it!
How about you, would you say yes to playing Bond?
Yes, but I would've half-arsed it.
To be on the safe side.
But I'll promise you this, if I get the Bond part, there will be phone calls from Bang!
Then it's all Çthere's been a mistakeÈ!
But do you think you would be able to do it?
I have no idea.
Have you ever looked in the mirror and said
ÇMy name is Bond ...È
No.
I've looked in the mirror and said Çmy name is BangÈ!
ÇMy name is Bang. Claes Bang.È
It's very close!
It's close!
Thank you so much, Claes Bang, it's fantastic having you here!